[Music]
can you believe this year marks 50 years
since barefoot in the park yeah I can
believe yes like a whole other lap well
there was a whole other lifetime did you
miss me today
no why not because you called me eight
times how have you changed over the
years yeah well you'd have to ask Jean
how she's changed but how I've changed
I just gotten older you know more
philosophical you know the older you get
the more you look back oh I see this is
what I did wrong well that wasn't so bad
that was good yeah that wasn't good you
don't do that when you're younger you
too busy moving forward would you be
interested in coming to my house
sometime to sleep with me what has
changed about him over that time that
you have observed and what has changed
about you wrinkles you don't have many
by the way what has changed
well I've gained confidence I used to
you know Bob sometimes there be times
when he wouldn't talk to me you know
except for what was in the script and
I'd think oh my god I've done something
wrong he doesn't like me you know I
always took it personally like it was my
fault and on our souls at night fifty
years later or however many it is when
he wouldn't speak you know I would just
say come on you look like you're
carrying the weight of the world on your
shoulders lighten up guy I just would
rib him about it and I realized oh I've
changed I you know I have more
confidence and I don't think it's my
fault see just a nice thing is he just a
quiet guy to work with I think he
carries the weight of the world on his
shoulders I don't know I don't know I
feel like I've gotten lighter as I've
gotten older hmm and I don't know how he
would describe it why do you think
you've gotten lighter as you i-i've
worked hard at it I'm you know I wasn't
always somebody that I liked very much
and I spent a lot of time trying to
become a better happier you know I come
from a long line of depressed people so
it takes some work
to get over that there were one time
that you could go back to or an age that
you could go back to what would it be
and you said right now yeah I'm about as
happy as I've ever been and I've worked
hard to get here and I've worked hard to
stay healthy and you know it
I think it's important to live life with
intention because otherwise you're just
sort of at the mercy of fate I mean we
all are in to some extent but I don't
know I just tried to take it by the
balls and make it my own life I'm
talking about and you still maintain
that healthy lifestyle sleep
are you still exercising a lot and
fitness it's not a lifestyle it's a life
I I lead a healthy life I try to to hang
with people who have good attitudes and
because you know who you spend time with
matters of positivity - yeah and try to
move towards the light rather than move
towards the darkness
[Music]
you
[Music]